hold on let me
actually uh check my camera once
that's better and where did my keynote
go
give me one second
can i start sharing please go ahead yeah
all right
okay you can see the slides
perfect yeah so next up we have rogue
mecca from ucla
and he's going to tell us how much less
is known
about learning undirected gaussian
graphical models than
we thought and some some partial answers
that are very interesting
i've got her in the head all right
before you start there's a
there's a build window in front of your
screen
there's a walk window a window of
a build window it says a building
effects window
bottom right oh there it is
okay oh i see i see all right
i see it here perfect okay is it gone
now
yeah perfect all right okay so
hello everybody today i'll talk about uh
learning gaussian graphical models and
it's kind of be
i'll tell you a little bit of what's
known and what we do and this is joint
work with jonathan kellner freddy kohler
and anchor moyeta all from mit
so the talk has three parts first i'll
talk about what ggfs are the motivation
for studying
them and then i'll talk about the
special model
special cases that we'll study that
arise in various
like you know learning applications
statistical physics and so on then i'll
tell our algorithm it is very simple
you know the algorithm is encapsulated
in just these two lines here
then i'll say a few words with the
analysis okay
and so what are gaussian graphical
models
uh so at the highest level i mean
they're just any
multivariated gaussian distribution
right so you have a multivariation
distribution
covariance sigma and throughout this
talk i'll use
the notation status i'll use the
notation from statistics
can you hear me i got some weird message
we can hear you okay okay
all right so and p will denote the
number of
variables right so is that it's
underlying dimension of the space that
we are working in so our samples are
always p
dimensional okay and
when we talk about ggns we're not
talking about gaussians but we are
talking
about something else so the focus
in this area is on the precision matrix
which is defined as the inverse of the
covariance matrix
and we'll use theta to denote the
precision matrix throughout the talk
so white look at the precision matrix
and this goes back
this goes back to this observation from
72 due to dumpster who showed
that the precision matrix encodes
valuable information about the
distribution
not just numerical properties but also
something called the conditional
independent structure of the
distribution
so more concretely suppose you have your
precision matrix theta which is sigma
inverse
then the support of the precision matrix
gives
us the dependency graph more concretely
suppose i build a graph where there are
p vertices corresponding to each of the
covariates
and add an edge between i and j if the
corresponding
entry in the precision matrix is
non-zero
right and dempster showed that the
distribution
has the following markov property with
respect to this graph
if there is no edge between two vertices
i and j
in this graph that is theta i j is 0
then x i and x j are independent
condition on the neighbors of a vertex i
so for example here
1 and 3 do not have an edge between them
so x1 and x3 are independent of each
other when you condition on neighbors of
1 let's say 2 and 5.
more generally they'll be independent
whenever you condition on any
cut in the graph
so that's why we'll start looking at
precision matrix
but another important thing that we'll
do is looking at the precision matrix
allows us to parameterize the complexity
of the model
differently and this is important
in the applications that you'll see so
we'll look
we'll think of gaussian graphical models
or gaussian distributions which are
simple
in the sense that their precision matrix
has small
small degree sorry the dependency graph
that comes out of the precision matrix a
small degree
and we'll think of the degree as being
much smaller than the underlying
dimension
so the dependency graph is sparse and
this is the assumption that makes the
formalism
non-trivial and useful when viewing
gaussian distributions in terms of the
precision matrix
okay so why look at this assumption and
why look at this particular way of
viewing gaussian distributions
for one this is actually very well
widely used
in to model statistical relations
between various variables especially
when you
think that there is a simpler dependency
structure than just looking at
covariances
and this is also used in concrete
applications for example to model some
networks that arise in biology
and in other domains
so to give an example and to gain some
intuition
this will be a running example
throughout this talk uh this is a very
simple example where the algorithmic
challenge that we look at
is easy to solve but it helps to keep
this in mind
so the example i'll call i'll call it
the random walk example so
here each x i is just the previous x i
plus
an independent gaussian distribution z i
so you have z one through z p which are
iid normal and then x
is x i minus one plus covariance of this
distribution looks something like this
you know they are increasing from 1
through all the way up to the number p
it's pretty regular in structure but
remarkably
if you look at the precision matrix of
this distribution
it's even nicer right so the precision
matrix
the inverse of the covariance is just
this simple tri-diagonal matrix
with twos on the diagonal minus ones on
the octagon
the nearest diagonal and the dependency
graph as can be seen
from kind of the equation that i wrote
down earlier
is is it just a path right so x i is x n
minus 1 plus z i so given x
i minus 1 you know every future x j
would be independent of the
past and that's exactly the path graph
okay so let's keep that example in mind
and the main challenge that you'll
address today is that of learning sparse
qgm's
so i'm giving you samples from a
gaussian distribution under the
assumption
that the underlying covariance made
underlying precision matrix
is sparse and our goal is to
approximately
learn the distribution to learn the
distribution
has two facets one is structural
learning meaning i just want to learn
the dependency graph
of the distribution and the other one is
to parameter to do parameter learning
that is not just learn the dependency
graph but to get some approximation for
either the covariance matrix the
precision matrix or in some other metric
for the distribution so today i'll
mainly focus
on structural learning often that is
kind of the crux of the problem
if you can do structured learning then
implicitly you can reduce the dimension
of the problem that you're working with
and then solve all the parameter
learning problems
uh using standard techniques so today
i'll focus on structural learning
meaning you're given samples x 1 through
x n so
n for us will denote the number of
samples and our goal is to learn the
dependency graph of the
gaussian graph of the model and the
challenge is that the number of samples
that we'll see
will be much less than the underlying
dimension p
and we think it will be possible because
we are making the assumption that the
dependency graph is sparse
each vertex has most few edges d
and the quantitative bounds that we want
are something like this
i'm going to assume that the degree is
much less than p so let's say a little
of p
and i want the dependency graph to have
uh to be learnable sample complexity
which is much
less than p again ideally we want the
number of samples to be
logarithmic in the dimension
and the dependence on d could be you
know poly t
or something as we see but it's
interesting even if you have something
which is exponential indeed
and as i said learning the dependency
graph is the core of the problem
and once you have that we can learn
parameters easily
and the ideal of course is to develop
simple algorithms with probable
guarantees
and that's what we'll strive toward so
let's go back to our example and look at
a toy version of the problem
this i'll call unknown order random walk
so here there is some permutation pi and
i have the same model as before but
under this permutation
so x pi of i is x minus 1 plus an
independent gaussian zi
and the covariance matrix will be
something you know
some jumbled matrix of the jumbled form
of the previous covariance matrix
the precision matrix here is you know
looks a lot messier
but still it sparse each row or column
has only three non-zero entries
and the dependency graph for this
particular one looks something like this
and the goal is you're not given any of
this information you're just given
samples from this gaussian
and you want to learn the hidden
permutation
what are the least number of samples you
need how fast can you learn it
this already seems like a pretty
interesting problem even though we
already know how to solve it
i think it's still interesting okay
so uh there's been a lot of work and
learning gaussian graphical models
especially there are these popular
packages which are
used in various domains for example when
i was doing some literature search i
found
a lot of literature psychology uses
glaso and klein to learn to fit ggm's
with
the data that they have all right so
let's look at what these methods show
glasses is work of friedman has stained
tip shirani from 2008
and there have been subsequent papers
analyzing it and more or less the best
guarantee we know for this method
is that it can learn ggms with sample
complexity that is d
squared times log p so the dependence on
the dimension underlying dimension p is
very good it's only logarithmic
and the degree dependence is also pretty
good it's just quadratic
but the analysis require
the ggn or the precision matrix to be
incoherent
which is some kind of strong form of
condition number assumption
on the precision matrix it won't define
what it precisely means
but even for the simple case of random
walk
this assumption is violated
and as we'll see even for many more
generally i think whenever you have
long-range correlations in your model
like if you have a
path somewhere in your model then the
assumption would be violated
similarly there's this work of uh
algorithm called client due to science
from 2011
they have a guarantee that gets again
log ethnic dependence on the dimension
but then they have a dependence on the
maximum ratio
of the entries in the covariance with
respect to the precision matrix
so if i normalize the diagonal index of
the precision matrix to be 1
how big is an entry in your covariance
matrix
and this is again some form of condition
number assumption
and this is also violated by the random
walk example
there this ratio would be p so you know
the bound would be really bad
but again uh whenever you have
these kinds of paths embedded in your
network i think the assumption will be
violated
okay so summary we have these
very nice methods but they need some
kind of well-conditionedness
assumption on the precision matrix and
these are violated by simple models and
the assumptions are not even scaled in
variant
under natural scalings and as we'll see
it's just it's not just that
you know our analysis is falling short
for these methods
as uh we'll see they also feel
empirically
on a small variant of the the
random walk example okay
so but before going ahead and trying to
solve the problem let's
try to think what is even possible for
this question
what can i solve information
theoretically
if you put aside the complexity
efficiency issues
how many samples do you need to learn a
general gtm
and this to formulate this precisely i
need to introduce one other parameter
for the
model and this i'll call kappa
and kappa of data theta is the precision
matrix remember
it's you look at any non-zero entry
in your precision matrix and you try to
check
what's the signal strength on this edge
how
big is this off diagonal entry with
respect to
the two corresponding diagonal entries
right so in some sense this ratio theta
i j divided by the square root
of the corresponding diagram entries
theta i theta j
measures a signal in just the two by two
matrices
corresponding to the edges you're not
looking at the whole matrix just two by
two sub matrices
so this could be much smaller and nicer
than
this could be much bigger and nicer than
the whole what happens when you look at
the whole condition number of the matrix
and this uh very recent and very nice
work of mishra buffer and local from
2018
showed that if you have any gtm
any ggm is identifiable the dependency
graph is identifiable
with sample complexity that is d log b
by kappa squared so
the number of samples is logarithmic in
the dimension
it depends on the degree is linear and
the dependence on
this edge parameter kappa is one over
kappa squared
and having some dependence on kappa
seems very natural
right you know if the edge strength is
very low
you should need many samples to even
identify that there's an edge even when
you're looking at
just the two by two case and for the
case of the random walk the ratio kappa
is just a half
if you look at the least half of
diagonal entry you just get half
and to complement this is an older word
due to van gaan right and ramachandran
from 2010
we showed that you need at least
log p or kappa square samples to learn
the
and this again makes sense because you
need roughly one or kappa squared
samples to notice that there is any
uh correlation
on any edge and then you know if you
have pu dimension then you might need
log b
examples any questions so far
please interrupt me if you have any
questions
okay so it seems very good i mean it
seems like the problem is completely
solved but there's one caveat and this
caveat is that this work of mr
wolfrain loco the way it works
essentially
is to do some kind of brute force search
on potential neighborhoods
so the runtime of the algorithm that
they give is p
to the o of d so for each vertex you
look at all possible d
neighborhoods and then check if that's
the right neighborhood
so as a result the runtime scales uh
exponentially with the dimension
as a question in a situation of kappa is
small small
then it results about learning the part
of the dependency graph on which kappa
is large
that's a very good question actually i
don't know a
concrete answer to that even information
theoretically
part of the reason might be that when
you do this kind of uh
you can't do like a brute force search
and so on so i'm not sure
that's a very good question any other
questions
okay so hold on hold on
okay so this dependence of p to the d is
problematic
even for moderate sized instances
you know if you think of d is 10 and p
is 100 that's already
okay somewhere difficult to implement
and run
so the question is can we do better can
we do better than
possibly enumerating or all possible
neighborhoods of a vertex
which we should think of as kind of
what's possible by proof of search
so the concrete question now is can i
learn gm's of degree
much smaller than the dimension and the
number of samples is
roughly d log p or kappa squared the
exact dependence on d and kappa could be
worse
but i really want the runtime of the
algorithm to be a fixed polynomial in p
something that doesn't grow with d can
you even get p to the little
of d that also seems not trivial
okay and the main result of this work is
that
this is actually true for a large class
of models that people have looked at
before
we can indeed achieve these goals so
i'll talk about these classes uh in a
little bit
uh there will be attractive models
symmetric diagonally dominant models and
more generally what i'll call walk
summable models
okay and the main result will be that
this simple greedy algorithm solves all
of these ill-conditioned cases
and it also actually recovers the
guarantees of glassware and client when
you have well conditionedness
so it's kind of you know achieves the
whole results and gets this newer
results for these potential air
conditioned models
okay so that's what i wanted to say
about what ggm's are the
the motivation for studying and what our
results are
now let me say a few words about the
special cases that we'll study
and the algorithm that we look at
so the first class of models we'll study
are attractive ggms
and a gtm we'll say is attractive
if all covariances are non-negative that
is any two variables
are positively correlated or they're
independent
equivalently if you look at the
precision matrix
then the off diagonals in the precision
matrix are all
negative that's when the
model is attractive and for example
uh this class of models called
gaussian-free fields which are
essentially
laplacians on some crafts which are as
in statistical physics and they are used
for
modeling gaussian processes they're all
they all belong to the class of
attractive ggms
the random walk model that we saw before
is also an attractive ggm i mean the
precision made risk was exactly this the
off diagonal entries were just minus one
or zero
so it's attractive
and even for attractive ggms if your
model is a
your models can be conditioned if you
have long paths
and they say at any time your graph has
a
path embedded in it somewhere or
something that looks like a path
embedded in
somewhere you get an ill-conditioned
model
and so what was known even for learning
attractive ggns
previously there were no efficient
algorithms again efficient means runtime
that is speed to the lit law of t
is something that beats and enumerating
or all possible neighborhoods
with sample complexity that is
logarithmic in the dimension p
and one of the results that we show is
that this is a simple algorithm that
i'll call a greedy prune
and we'll see in a little bit and it
learns attractive models
with sample complexity that is d log p
or kappa squared
so the dependence on on p is logarithmic
the dependence on kappa is also right
one over kappa squared
and there's a multiplicative d in front
and the runtime is quadratic
and this is off from the information
theoretical optimal sample complexity by
a factor of d
so there's a lower bound for attractive
gems as well but you need at least log
pure kappa square samples
okay and so we'll get back to this
algorithm and how to prove this later on
but let me now talk about the a more
general class of models
and the most general one that we looked
at in this work which are rock summable
gaussian graphical models so a gtm
is walk summable if
if doing the following operation on the
precision matrix
leaves the matrix still positive
semi-definite concretely
suppose i have my precision matrix theta
now i build a new matrix where i make
every off diagonal entry in negative so
i replace every theta i j
with the negative minus absolute value
of theta i j
minus of absolute value theta energy if
the resulting matrix is still positive
semi-definite
then we call the matrix walk somewhat
and these were introduced by mariota
johnson and wilski in 2006
and this generalized many classes of
models
like attractive gtms if your model is
attractive all the off diagonals are
negative so doing this operation doesn't
change it so you remain positive
semi-definite
uh the things called pairwise
normalizable which also arise from
statistical physics they are voximable
something called non-frustrated models
they are waximable
and there's something called symmetric
diagonally dominant which we'll look at
later on
and they're also walk some of them
okay so this is the most general class
that we look at
and they're actually well studied both
in the context of ggm's as well as in
other
contexts in statistical physics
and the best previous result for
learning vox mobile gtms
it actually goes back even older than
the work of mr buffer and local
uh due to anand kumar
and others from 2012 who gave an
algorithm which runs vox mobile ggm's
with logarithmically many samples where
runtime was again p to the o of d
and the second result that we have is
that walk some mobile models are
actually learnable
efficiently with quadratic runtime and
dependence which is logarithmic in the
dimension
the dependence on the degree d and kappa
are polynomial inverse of you have b
squared by capital six
we also give a more sort of
sophisticated algorithm
which kind of combines the greedy method
that we have along with the standard
optimization procedures
which gets d log p or capital four
dependence
but i won't talk about this hybrid
method today
but i'll focus instead on the slightly
worse sample complexity with giving
better
greedy pro okay
so now let me talk about the algorithm
that we use
and this is kind of degree method that's
been used very effectively for
learning discrete gaussian graph
discrete dactyl models
starting with the work of bressler and
more recently with the work of hamilton
coiler and mitra
and also for by bressler
coiler and moitra from their question
looks fine uh
yeah there's a looks like there's a
quick question that someone asked is the
dependence on cap but necessary
for [ __ ] somebody so i guess that
capital the fourth whether whether it's
uh
oh um i don't think so i think kappa
squared
is enough it's just that i don't know
how to
do it you don't think there's a
statistical computational gap there
at least in terms of kappa
i don't know i don't think that yes so
walk some mobile models i think we
should be able to get uh log p or kappa
squared uh our methods inherently hit a
bottleneck in that
you cannot do kappa square but it would
be surprising if there is a gap
surprising to me does this this
correspond to like faster slow rates and
less so
yes yes exactly yeah but i'm not here
are you leveraging like fast rate
analysis
uh
i mean actually you you you can use
fast rate here but the bottleneck is not
bad it shows up in how much
improvement that we make like in the
analysis somewhere you have to show that
you know when you add a vertex you make
some progress
and based on that you need to get some
accuracy
in your solver the solver is pretty good
but
uh somehow the in the analysis the
accuracy that you need
for it to go through that's off i think
okay i mean cool thank you it's a good
question
okay so let me go back here
so we have uh the similar greedy
approach for discreet gms
we're kind of following the same outline
from what's been used with discrete
graphical models
and the outlier is something like this
you try to recover
the neighborhood of each vertex in
parallel so you know you're trying to
learn the graph but let me focus on a
single vertex and trying to learn now
the neighborhood of this single vertex
and do it for each vertex in parallel
and the way we'll solve it for one
vertex is the following
first i'll build a candidate
neighborhood set you know
maybe grow at one vertex at a time until
i hit some number of vertices
and along the way i might have added
some spurious vertices
so after i've done adding growing this
neighborhood
i'll prune out some vertices i'll look
at which vertices are absolutely
informational or
absolutely contributing something and
throughout the remaining
so this is the outline so let's talk
about how you
do the second step so how do we grow the
neighborhood
so recall our input is a sample from a
sparse gtm
and output should be now we're focusing
on designing a neighborhood for a single
vertex vertex one
and the idea for us is the following so
we'll look
we'll start with the empty set and while
the set s
or vertices that we've added is small
enough
we'll add the vertex that gives the
maximum
decrease in the conditional variance of
x1
so in some sense we are adding the
vertex that gives us a max
bank per buck in terms of explaining my
current variance
so you just find the j which minimizes
our estimate for the conditional
variance of x 1 coupled with what we
already saw
and x j and add that and we repeat this
until some budget
so this is similar to what's been done
for discrete graphical models
but the potential uh is
i think simpler here and different
and as it turns out somewhat
surprisingly
this method is actually equivalent if
you are familiar with the corporate
sensing literature
what minimizing this conditional
variance is actually equivalent
to orthogonal matching pursuit you can
build a sparse regression problem
and when you set up the language right
this greedy method is equivalent to
running orthogonal matching pressure
but we'll adopt the greedy terminology
because it makes
things cleaner and easier to analyze
okay so that's the growing
neighborhood phase and next phase is to
prune a neighborhood
and this is again simpler simple enough
so you look at each vertex
and you check is it actually giving me
some value so
if dropping this vertex doesn't hurt
your conditional variance too much
you drop it okay so for it to be
eligible to be in the set it should
actually
make a noticeable difference
and once again you only have estimates
so you have to work with the estimates
and not with the actual
conditional variances
okay so that's the algorithm and before
talking about how to analyze it and what
the precise results i've already
mentioned let me say a few words about
some
experiments we actually did some
experiments and some real-world graphs
which turned out to be walk-summable but
let me describe what happens when you
have a toy example
so a simple challenge example is the
following i have the random walk example
just a simple path on
half the vertices and then remaining
half i'm splitting into isolated four by
four clicks
so the precision matrix is path plus
clicks the max degree is three
and because of the path this matrix this
position matrix is ill-conditioned so
the bounds for
glass oil and claim do not apply here
and the precision matrix pictorially
looks something like this
you have you know this 4x4 blocks on the
upper half and then you have the
track diagonal matrix in the lower half
okay so what happens when you run the
all the methods
something like this happens you know you
have glaso climb and greedy here i'll
finish the simulation
and if you look at the final outputs you
can see that greedy does remarkably well
in recovering the graph whereas the
climate glass or have
many have several spurious entries
and you can also see it in
in plots this is the normalized error of
the different methods
but more important is the following
graph it shows the number of samples you
need to record the graph
so if i change the intensity the weight
on the cliques of the edges of the
clique
you can spoil the different methods
performance
so for instance if the intensity was set
to 0.95
then the sample complexity of climb
seems to grow linearly
so the number of samples you need to
recover the graph under pretty loose
criteria
it seems to grow linearly with the
dimension whereas greedy prune
does very well and here actually when
the intensity is 0.95 surprisingly glass
also does well but on the other hand
if i change the intensity a little bit
to 0.7
then suddenly glasso starts growing
whereas uh
greedy prune still stays very good
and finally there was this one method
which i didn't talk about but
something that people proposed as a
heuristic and implemented it as men
house employment method
uh it's kind of a lasso uh based on
main housing boom and estimator it's
kind of based on lasso
and on a simple random walk it starts
growing
linearly whereas pd prune again works
well
so in all of these methods in all of
this variations
greedy print does well but the existing
methods do not seem to
have logarithmic dependency for
recovering the
graph okay
so in summary here are the main results
the greedy print learns attractive
models and gives walk some mobile model
and learns voxelmag models with somewhat
similar but slightly worse quantitative
parameters
and you can also recover the guarantees
of glass and climb under
the assumptions that they were analyzed
with it's also empirically better
and one nice thing about our method as
well as even glass and climb is that
even the everything i talked about was
in terms of gaussian distributions
uh there is a version of the problem
which makes sense which also works for
non-gaussian distributions
so suppose for some reason i know that i
have some distribution which need not be
gaussian
but its precision matrix is sparse and
the distribution
has good tails can i learn
the precision matrix
oops hold on
the questions popped up now run away
there you go yeah so if the distribution
is
non-gaussian we can still approximate
the precision matrix
as long as the precision matrix is
parsed and the distribution has you know
polynomial or exponential sub gaussian
tails
okay so let me now uh in the last few
minutes say a few words about
the analysis of the algorithm for the
two cases
so just to recall we are trying to learn
gems greedily have samples and then
you're trying to output the dependency
graph these are the guarantees
but let me want to tell you so the
analysis for attractive case is actually
very simple and goes back to
super modularity of the conditional
variance function
so we are fixing the vertex x1 and let
me now define a function on the subsets
of the remaining vertices
so f of s is the conditional variance of
x1 given excess
and this is all result from 2006 and
independently discovered in 2012
saying that if the matrix if the
gaussian distribution you started out
with is attractive
then this function f is super modular
it's
always monotonically decreasing but when
you have it an attractive model
it's also super modular and why super
super marginality just means that the
net benefit of adding a vertex
j to our existing set decreases as your
set increases
and why is super modularity useful well
optimizing super modular functions is
extremely very well understood
and like greedy algorithm we know finds
the minimizer of the function
which is kind of makes sense now it sort
of makes sense that greedy works
greedy plume would work for attractive
models
so are we done in analysing attractive
models
almost a couple of caviars which are
somewhat technical to address but you
know you have to work through them one
is that we don't have
exact uh conditional variances we have
only estimates for them so you have to
make sure that your estimates are good
enough
without using too many samples and the
second one is that
you have to argue that somehow
if you miss a vertex you will be
noticeably away from optimum
and that you know every vertex in your
neighborhood is actually relevant
and this takes a little bit more work
but both of these are more technical
than like conceptual hurdles i'd say
okay so uh i think
in the interest of time i won't be able
to go into too many proofs of our other
results but let me tell you
uh proof of the super modularity result
which i think is very nice
though the original papers have somewhat
different proofs
but here's a simple linear algebraic
proof so let me
normalize the precision matrix so that
the diagonal entries are one
and normalization doesn't change the
super modularity so it suffices to super
modularity
of the condition covariance function
conditional variance function under this
normalization
and use the determinant formula and some
linear algebra to
see that for this is true for any model
actually that the conditional variance
of x 1 given x s is exactly
the number of paths actually this i
should be one but the number of cycles
in your graph
uh if you take you take a cycle in your
graph
that starts at one ends at one but does
not touch
any vertex in s and for each such cycle
you take the product of the edge weights
uh with their negative sign
okay so for each cycle starting at one
ending at one
which doesn't touch s you take the
product of the edge weights
and if the graph is if the model is
attractive then each theta i j is
negative so negative theta is positive
so adding a bunch of positive numbers
here
so the difference between f of s and f
of s union j
is the sum on cycles that touch
the vertex j but don't touch this set
s and clearly now
if i take a bigger set s or bigger set t
this the set of cycles you are summing
over
is smaller right so the condition is
that you should not touch
s there are fewer cycles which do not
touch t compared to do not touch s
so you are taking a smaller sum so super
modularity would fall
okay so this is the proof of super
marginality
now let's go back to walk summable
models
and here the conditional variance
function which is again
the same function that we see using our
greedy algorithm
is no longer super modular and it is not
even weakly super modular
under various notions of weakness which
were studied and
known to suffice for greedy optimization
but it doesn't satisfy
any of those guarantees so why does
greedy work
even though the function is not super
modular here
so the analysis kind of has two steps
first we reduce to the case of symmetric
diagonally dominant matrices something
that are easier to study
and once we go to sdd matrices we show
some structural results and the most
important of which is that
every neighbor would have a noticeable
effect
on your conditional variance so let me
elaborate on these in the next two
minutes
so the first result uh first before
talking about them i need to define what
sdd matrices are and
a matrix data is std if the diagonal
entry
is bigger than the sum of absolute n
absolute values
of the entries in the row of the
remaining entries in the row
and any symmetric diagonally dominant
matrix is psd
and there's this very nice observation
from 2009 that
or maybe even earlier in some folklore
results that if a matrix status blocks a
maple
then there is a diagonal scaling of
theta
such that the resulting matrix is
symmetric diagonally dominant
and since the greedy algorithm actually
is a
scale invariant when you do diagonal
scalings
showing it works for walk simple
matrices
is equivalent to showing it works for
symmetric diagonally dominant matrices
so we can focus our analysis just on std
matrices
okay so let's now go
to sdd matrices and the main punch line
of the analysis is the following lemma
it gives which gives a bound on the
conditional variances
to state the bond without much notation
let me make
one more normalizing assumption which is
that the diagonal entries of my theta
are one okay and if you don't have this
you just have to scale the final bond
appropriately
but if you have this then the kappa
condition becomes something very nice
it says that every non-zero entry in my
precision matrix
is at least kappa in absolute value
okay and the main technical lemma we
have is that
if your theta is sdd symmetric
diagonally dominant
and satisfies this normalization theta i
is one
then the conditional variances are all
bounded that is take any two edges and
vertices i and j
then the variance of x i given x j
is independent of the dimension p in
fact is at most one over kappa
okay and this is very nice because
without the conditioning the variance
could be very large
even when theta is one the variance
could be as large as p
for instance if you go back to the
random walk model the
variances were growing with i the index
i in particular the vertices in the last
half
would have variance which is omega p
right whereas all of the conditional
variances are always just one because
you are adding exactly one additional
gaussian
okay and this is not true this bound
that you know variance of x i given xj
is small
is not true for general sparse precision
matrices
even when you have this kappa guarantee
okay and why is this useful uh
so the main problem with the earlier
methods like you know glass of incline
was that
when you look at the analysis they need
some assumption saying that the
variances of x i
are small related to the entries in the
precision matrix
but now we are saying okay you might
that might have been false to begin with
but if a condition on one neighbor then
you're kind of in the good
well-conditioned case
once a conditional neighbor the
variances are all very small one word
cap
and we can exploit this uh
to kind of use the earlier algorithms
after finding one vertex
and this can be done with few samples
and so on
okay so uh that's what i wanted to say
in terms of proof
but you know just as a plug this is a
hint
rather towards the proof of this
statement we reduce this
proving the statement for std matrices
to proving it for laplacian matrices
graph laplacians and there
this inequality follows from you know
some application of triangle inequality
for effective resistance metric
if you know what they are okay
so that's how i wanted to say about the
analysis and in summary
uh the main challenge that we talked
about was that of learning gtms
degree d pairwise correlation is kappa
and we want runtime which is p to the
little low of t
i don't want to enumerate or all
possible neighborhoods
and can you get sample complexity that
is you know poly lot p
i'm allowing you you know let's say even
arbitrary dependence on d
and kappa but you should really be able
to do
poly d poly one over kappa and the
problem is variable study it is
practically important
and today i describe some algorithm you
know a greedy algorithm which solves a
problem some interesting special cases
okay but let me skip this bigger picture
we've seen many of that already
and there are many questions for ggms
that are open
so the main question i'd say is you know
other other
you know uh classes of models that you
can solve
even testing is completely unknown if i
give you
a ggm if i give you samples from a gg
i'm gonna tell you okay here's my graph
g
tell me whether this graph g is the
right one or not
we don't know how to solve it what
happens if i have a gta but now there's
an additional
aspect that some variables are hidden
i'm missing some observations
and finally you know given that the
general general problem seems difficult
to solve
is there some reason some gap is there
some computation versus statistical gap
here
and i actually think that the general
problem is hard my belief is that there
is no
something like p to the little of the
algorithm to record the structure for
general gtms the sample complexity that
is
poly logarithmic in the dimension p be
happy if you prove me wrong but
that's i think where the complexity
stands
okay so let me stop with that
well thanks for your very interesting
talk dude do
people have any questions
yeah it's good great talk sorry i have
some questions um
so like climb and like a variety of
other
uh sort of structural learning problems
it usually say
start with you know i want to minimize
some some i want to optimize and
function you know subjectively
constrained and then it goes about
solving it right
did you have such an optimization like
this your greedy algorithm is a solution
to a particular optimization problem
that's actually a very good question uh
i don't think we have that
[Music]
so in some sense uh
yeah i don't have a good answer to that
i don't think we have a single
optimization problem
solving which would give us this which
is kind of weird right because
you could have thought of omp itself
orthogonal matching pursuit which is our
algorithm as one way to solve the
lasso objective right but if you said
start with that as your optimization
problem then that doesn't work but the
algorithm that
people use to solve that optimization
problem somehow works
right right so it's yeah i don't have a
good objective problem you know good
optimization question solving which
would work here
i see thank you uh could you repeat the
the pruning step because i i didn't
understand the pruning step
sure so the pruning step basically
checks
where we go yeah it should be here
right so use you have your set s now for
each vertex in this set
you drop that vertex and see if the
conditional variance has
increased by more than let's say 1.01
factor
so when i drop it the conditional
variance could increase
and if it increased too much then
you don't drop it but if it didn't
increase too much meaning it didn't
change
when you dropped the vertex you drop
that vertex and go on
i see i see yeah thank you and how do
you choose tau
uh tau is actually chosen uh based on
uh in the paper we kind of have a
formula for it
i definitely don't remember it offhand
but it's something that depends on the
degree d
and kappa you need to have some upper
bounds on them
to make this equation work
have you guys tried running your
algorithm on some data sets
oh sorry uh
so let me ask a guy first uh so yeah
definitely we tried it on
um well we i mean freddie tried it on
some examples uh and basically it seemed
to work pretty well and
one of the things that we tried actually
was to see how realistic this
member assumption was and for this
uh freddie pulled up some you know some
networks that arised in
gene regulatory networks and then
checked if they were
close to being walk summable and
surprisingly uh
they were reasonably close to being walk
somewhat
under some notion of closeness which is
pretty interesting
so i'd say maybe there's some evidence
of you know that this could be useful in
practice
yeah yeah so could you elaborate a bit
on the conjecture you made in the last
slide
right so let me go back
so the conjecture is basically saying
that uh
if i give you general samples from a ggm
we know that d log p or kappa squared
sample
supplies information theoretically and
there is a p
to the d algorithm where you kind of
enumerate or all possible neighborhoods
and my conjecture you know or maybe i
should even just a question but my
conjecture is that
there is no p to the little of d
algorithm
which would recover the dependency graph
given
only poly logarithmic in p samples and
the dependence on degree d
is d you know polynomial in d and
polynomial one over kappa
but you don't it's not like you have a
specific uh
like uh argument like in mind or at
least
no no no i mean i wish i had like it's
not even this is a problem where the
complex i think is kind of
even more open than many other problems
because we don't even have any sort of
potential
hard instances
it doesn't like you know it's not clear
what say what would be a hard gtm we've
been trying to
come up with hard instances and then we
came up with algorithms to break them
and so on so
i don't have anything more concrete than
this
and the fact that we tried work we tried
to solve it for
you know some time
but but i'm confused about your
conjecture a little bit because
uh we don't even know if it's hard you
know with
with with a improved dependence on one
of our kappa right
uh what do you mean oh yeah yeah so this
is a stronger conjecture than like you
know we don't even know if you can do it
with d
log p or kappa square samples i
definitely agree it's this kind of the
most general
and strongest conjecture you can make
right but i'm saying you know uh either
you'd get something like uh
this or nothing
yeah yeah it's just just you know there
are weaker conjectures you could
first have yeah yeah yeah i mean i know
but like since
there's so much ambiguity might as well
make the strongest garbage
okay fair enough
awesome well thanks to both of our
speakers this morning
um the next talk starts in six minutes
and eric price will tell us about some
interesting new results
on learning trees so i guess feel free
to go to gather town if you want or
get some tea all right let's get some
coffee
exactly yeah so
see you all then keep announced